hey everyone is cereth register nurse
sorry and calm and in this video i'm
going to demonstrate how to change an
ostomy pouching system in the previous
video i did an in clicks review over
colostomies and it we asked me so be
sure to check out that video so first
let's talk about the supplies you will
need you will need a pouching system
here I have a one piece pouching system
and it has a skin barrier also called a
wafer for land and it's attached to the
pouch so it comes together and some
people have the two-piece systems and
the skin barrier and the pouch are
separate and they snap on to each other
whenever you're placing the system I'm
also what you may need that I don't have
right here you may need a barrier ring
and the barrier ring will go around the
stoma for extra protection in case the
patient's having a lot of skin breakdown
from still getting on to the skin and
the skin barrier just isn't really
protecting it so the barrier ring would
go around the stoma and you would set
the skin barrier on top it out and then
also with this particular system we have
a clip so be sure you get the clip if
your patient needs one and some bags
will velcro and that's how they close
but this particular one uses a clip
another thing you will need is a
measuring card and these come in the
kits usually and you will just be using
it to measure the stoma because you will
be cutting around your barrier what size
the sum is so you can apply it to the
skin so you'll need a pin you will also
need some ostomies scissors these
scissors are special and that they're
curved and they have a blunt tip so you
can achieve a circular cut instead of a
jagged cut onto the barrier and of
course you will need gloves
you will need some wash cloths to clean
the stoma and to dry it and it's how
just to prevent any leakage of stool on
to the patient first perform hand
hygiene and then you will dawn gloves
then give us how and place that on your
patient to protect their gown and their
skin from any soul by your change in the
system and some things you want to keep
in mind while doing this you'll want to
change the system about every three to
five days and you will empty the pouch
whenever it becomes one-third to half
way full and here as you can see this
definitely needs to be empty but we're
changing the system so it's good and and
while you're doing this you want to
allow the patient to help you as much as
possible because they need to become
independent in doing this because I'll
be doing it whenever they go home now if
you are a nurse who has a very sensitive
nose and you're bothered by odorous
smells and you need to be prepared for
this because whenever you're changing an
awesome e bag there are some pungent
odors and to help with this you can
maybe wear a mask I've even known some
colleagues to put vapor rub around their
nose before they go in to change the
pouch to prevent the smell and so you
can have a menthol smell and you notice
you're changing it so just be aware of
that and prepare beforehand so what
we're going to do is we are going to
remove the system and whenever you do
this you want to do this when the gut is
the least active because you don't want
to be changing it and all the stool is
just coming out on you because you're
going to be making a huge mess so
usually in the morning before breakfast
before the patient eats is the best time
or ask the patient because they'll know
when there's some of hits off police but
if this is a brand new summer that may
not know so what you're going to do is
you're just gently going to remove the
adhesive because this is the one piece
system and it has it's sticking to the
skin and if you have difficulty removing
it you can use some adhesive remover
okay so we have that off and what you're
going to do is just discard this
appropriately then you're going to take
your washcloth with warm water try not
to use any soap
have lotion powders creams or any
alcohol containing products around the
summer on the stoma because it caused
some problems and before you do it you
want to make sure you're looking around
the stoma and looking for any skin
breakdown like extreme redness now as
you can see in this example there is
redness around the stoma this is not
good and what is happening is that stool
is leaking probably under that skin
barrier and getting on to the skin so
whenever you're replacing the bear at
the pouching system you may want to use
a barrier ring and make sure that you're
cutting the skin barrier should fit the
stoma appropriately so it's not leaking
onto the skin and what you'll do is
you'll start around the skin and just
gently clean the skin making sure to get
any residue off and then you will clean
your stoma and the stoma is not painful
to the patient remember it's just the
inside of the intestines flipped inside
out so it's not painful for you to clean
the stoma and make sure you have it all
clean then you will Pat the area dry you
want this to be very dry because if it's
not dry your skin barrier is not going
to stick to the skin hand firm if you
have a patient who has a lot of hair on
the abdomen because you know hair grows
back you may want to trim the hair
because number one it will stick better
and when you remove next pouch change
it's not going to wax or hair off which
can be very painful so make sure you do
that then discard your gloves and
perform hand hygiene and put on a new
pair of gloves now we're going to
measure our stoma using our measuring
card and the reason we want to do this
is because we're going to be cutting a
hole on our skin barrier and this is
going to be going on the skin and we
don't want to cut it too big
we're still the leak
to the skin or cut it too small where it
will constrict the stoma
so we want to measure appropriately and
you'll take your measuring card you'll
put it flush up against the skin and you
want about a 1/8 inch an area around the
stoma so this right here way too big and
that is too big as well let's try this
one and that one looks like it's perfect
you have around the stoma about a 1/8
inch and look and see what it reads and
it says 45 mil millimeters so we're
going to match that up on our bag and
trace it
now some skin barriers are already
labeled and they have a nice little
outline of where your measurement is
like here it already says 45 millimeters
so I don't have to trace it but
sometimes skin barriers don't have that
so what you would have to do is put your
measuring card over it and trace where
you had your measurement so you was on
the 45 millimeter and you would just
create a circle on the barrier and then
cut it out now I'm going to take my
awesome scissors and I'm going to cut
around the 45 millimeter mark
and just go back through and make sure
everything's nice and round and there's
no jagged edges because you don't want
this to wear on the stoma or on the
patient's skin and we had it in looks
good now let's put the new passing
system on what I like to do is I like to
snap my bag and make sure it's closed
before I put it on just in case
something leaks out so this is the clip
like I said the beginning some velcro
and these clips can be a little bit
cumbersome to you so get familiar with
how to use them what you do is you take
the end of it the [ __ ] and you just
simply fold it over the clip like so and
then you just press that down and it
snaps in place and you have your little
clip on and then you will take the
backing off of your skin barrier and if
you're going to place a barrier ring now
would be the time to do that so you
place the barrier ring on around the
stoma and then you would place your skin
barrier your wafer flange on over the
stoma and you want to make sure that it
fits really good and that you smooth it
around the sign so it's sticking to the
skin appropriately and feels very good
now some things you want to keep in mind
if this is a new and awesome e for the
patient you want to explain to them that
they need to be checking their bags
every so often because it can inflate
with gas and they will need to do what's
called burping their bag and to burp
this particular bag you would take off
this cliff and just let the air out
now some awesome e bags do have a filter
that allows the gas to escape and
prevents an odorous smell from coming
out so you just have to look to see what
you have and just warn the patient that
when they do relieve the gas from there
that they may want to make sure that no
one's around if someone's visiting them
or something like that because it can
produce an odorous smell and as the
nurse you want to be checking this as
well because our patients tend to wear
those big bulky gowns and they can't
include you being able to see the bags
in plates so you'll have to pull the
gown back and actually look at the bag
so that is how you change an ostomy
pouching system thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos